good morning everyone and I hope you're
all awake had a good breakfast and are
ready to see some amazing stuff
welcome to the Oscar week animated
feature event where we get to celebrate
this year's nominees and get a chance to
peek into their journeys tomorrow night
one of them will win an Academy Award
but today they are all nominees equal on
a rare community of excellence this year
we have a wonderfully diverse group of
films from all over the world done in 2d
3d hand-drawn and stop motion we have
tones ranging from something you'd show
the kids to things you'd probably want
to hide from them unless you want to
somehow to not use a bandsaw this is a
great time for animation a time for
experimentation diversification new
stories and opportunities it will be
exciting to see what comes next
thank you to the dedicated Academy staff
for putting all this together all the
lunches dinners screenings speech
coaching sessions they work harder than
anyone so let's give them a big round of
applause
and we would like to sincerely thank the
rudiment found family foundation for
helping to underwrite our Oscar week
public programs and we're thrilled that
Jay and Shira Reutimann are joining us
for this morning
and we'd like to acknowledge them for
their generous support
please stand if you don't mind so people
could see
and now let's get to the good stuff
you've been waiting for our hosts and
moderators this morning need don't know
introduction but they're gonna get one
anyway Phil Lord and Chris Miller met in
college and I've been working together
ever since
writing directing and producing both
live-action and animated series and
features such as Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs 21 Jump Street the lego movie
and of course spider-man please please
welcome last year's Academy Award
winners for Best Animated Feature Phil
and Chris Miller
hey guys how's it going oh it's a full
house got into animation sorry I didn't
have to talk to anybody it's a real
bait-and-switch
Chris it is true and all of the awesome
nominees today also have had to talk a
lot in front of a bunch of people for
many many months and it's way less
comfortable it turns out that making
things is talking about the things that
you make that is why you come up with
these things called talking points and
those are meant to orient people to
what's so special about your movie and
your job as a filmmaker is to say only
those talking points and the job of
everyone around you is to make sure you
only say those talking points and in the
process the cell walls of your neurons
deteriorate they break open and the
plasma mixes with everything else and
your head turns to mush at the metabolic
level you are no longer a sentient being
you are a talking point so you visit all
the animation studios in LA in San
Francisco and you deliver the talking
points and if you are so lucky and you
win an Annie Award or an AARP award
which is a real thing
I just made up right now but actually it
is a real thing I looked it up earlier
and you still give the talking points
there is a middle school in the Bay Area
that you go to to give the talking
points to the children of the people who
work at Pixar
so that at dinner that night they will
give the talking points to their parents
when you go to London for the BAFTAs and
you give more talking points but this
time you use the U in color but you
don't pronounce a clue
no nobody tells you that you're trying
to fit in I'm like oh this film is so
colorful
boy what a mistake one mistake you're
all over the Guardian the guardian'
excuse me and then you know you're very
cold because London in January is
basically a sheep to freezing rain and
you get sick and you give the talking
points to the the doctor that does a
house call at your London hotel and
gives you free medicine because they
have a great system there anyway and
then you go to Los Angeles okay and
you're still sick because the Tamiflu
hasn't kicked in and you have like this
witch doctor that like prescribes you
yoga and B vitamins and
true it's true the envelopes have been
printed they've been sealed we were
doing it in the back I have a lot of
paper cuts they've been placed in a safe
that is right below this stage not true
so we can just friends coffee shop so
it's gonna be a lot of fun today
me a lot of fun and you know there's
gonna be a really awesome TV show
tomorrow night and the whole world is
gonna watch and everyone's gonna look
fantastic
but the reason for all of this is what
we're doing here it's to create a
community among filmmakers is to share
the craft with all of you nice people
who somebody came here at 7:30 to line
up God love you guys in the fog the
London Fog and and and and we we all had
like a nice dinner a couple nights ago
and and the nice thing about what the
Academy does every year is it really
does bring filmmakers together and
that's the whole thing and this year all
five movies are beautiful gorgeously
crafted and so unique and different from
one another but the one thing they have
in common is that many people work
together to make something really
special and so we're super excited to
that we get to talk to representatives
from each of these films today do you
guys like A's because we are going to
give some cues to precipitate those A's
you better like them because we've got
two hours of both cues and A's all the
heirs will come join each other for our
super Q some bonus cues anyway so we're
gonna get started and before each film
we're gonna show a clip from each movie
and so the first clip is from this
wonderful gorgeous film that we all know
by the acronym of HT t yd h th w yes
How to Train Your Dragon the Hindu world
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world dean deblois Bradford Lewis and
Bonnie Arnold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning fine surprises he's all
yours
[Music]
you know and it may be blessed with
rolling but just between us you have the
brains
one
[Music]
[Music]
right but it's time I was so busy
fighting for a world that I wanted I
didn't think about what you needed
you've looked after us for long enough
time to look after yourselves
good girl
all right comfy so long beast
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
go on but lead them to the hidden world
you'll be safe there
safer than you could ever be with me mm
that's okay how have you do and I want
you to be free our world doesn't deserve
you yet
[Music]
[Music]
go toothless
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Dean you made me cry again I'm so mad at
you you guys it's so beautiful thank you
congratulations
that clip I want you to talk a little
bit about saying you know putting a
button on a whole trilogy and that you
made with all of these people the the
metaphor is not lost on me it can't be
lost on you guys yeah I mean it was the
goal from from the moment that Jeffrey
Katzenberg and DreamWorks wanted to make
a sequel I pitched out the idea let's do
a trilogy let's do three acts of one
coming of age it seemed like a good idea
at the time we could touch upon
different crossroads and age the
characters up on screen so the audience
could grow up with our characters but at
the end of the day it was inspired by a
conversation with the book author
Cressida Cowell and she was trying to
explain what happened to dragons in her
last book and if you know the books in
the movies the stories are very
different but I thought that was such a
like a stirring and emotional and
mysterious goal that if we could take
that on ourselves as yes we will see
hiccup come of age and become this wise
Viking chief but in so doing would have
to say goodbye to the Dragons as well
and how that would happen and you know
how that would sort of be the trigger of
his completion of his transformation we
had that as like a vague goal and we
know we knew we would get to it but it
never wavered from that let me ask you
are you best friends with Roger Deakins
and what is his email
[Laughter]
but seriously did you what did you learn
from him and what did he learn from your
process and do you deserve an Oscar for
1917 I like to think that we really
turned his career around yeah that's
true
and dragging there for a while no we so
the interesting thing is Chris Sanders
and I when we joined How to Train Your
Dragon it was kind of late in the game
and we were new to CG animation we came
from a hand-drawn background so we we
quickly realized that the the layout
Department that does all of the camera
angles and compositions and camera
movement was separated by months in the
pipeline from the lighting department
and these two didn't really do a lot of
talking so coming from hand-drawn
animation and work booking we knew that
how could you settle on a composition
before you know the light and shadow
seems strange to us so we decided that
we would reach out to a cinematographer
everyone had great admiration for and
and invite them in and maybe they could
do a workshop or two with us we knew
that Roger had spent time with the Pixar
folks and wall-e and he did that he
spent a couple days doing lighting
setups in their atrium and talking to
them and you can see the effect of that
in that first act of wall-e so we were
we were expecting to do something
similar but he yeah he liked the project
in the pitch he went well he went home
and talked to his wife James about it
and then got in touch with us and said
I'd like to join the whole production
which meant we had him from the very
outset with assembling all sorts of
photo reference and kind of mood and
atmosphere boards to working with our
storyboard artists working with our
previous artists advising us on you know
how to combine and truncate and rethink
shots in the Edit and then all the way
through the end working with the
lighters and right to the final digital
intermediate color correction incoming
call from Roger Deakins luckily our
process is so long that he could
actually go and do other things and we'd
still be on the same shot when he got
back later
and so Bonnie how did the experience
change through the decade-plus of making
these movies and and how was your
collaboration with Dean and the other
artists on the film and how has that
evolved over the years well um I guess
you know in the beginning it took a
really long time to figure out how to
take and I know a lot of us have been
through this at work in the business
take up something that was basically a
picture book and turn it into something
that's sort of you know way more epic
and that that sometimes there's a bit of
a struggle in the beginning and it takes
a while but I'm proud to say that we
worked with a lot of the same creative
team led by Dean and Chris in the
beginning and Dean picked up the mantle
and has seen us through the end but I
think that made a big difference is to
have you know a creative team and some
people sort of came and went and plus it
along the way
and luckily for us Brad came along on
movie three and helped us get to the
finish line and but I think all along
Dean had a real vision especially after
the scramble of the first movie of what
the whole thing could look like and that
kind of sauce through three different
Studios releasing the movies and you
know up the ups and downs of what that
might be and somehow we kind of kept our
eye on the prize I mean we talked early
on about what that ending this ending
would be and we kind of had it a little
bit everybody held slightly different
vision of what that would be but I'm
proud to say that we got to the you know
we all three movies kind of came
together all three have been nominated
for Academy Awards and we're all so good
I mean one thing I think is really
interesting is all three of you are
animation veterans who've worked in all
different expressions of the medium and
this movie is so innovative visually
it's using the latest technology but to
me the star is this very classical the
movement of these characters and of
these dragons and how they express
themselves without language right tell
me about what it's like to you know be
on the vanguard of the technology and
kind of retained the values of the of
your training
well we both speak to this but we have
Simon Otto in the audience he's our head
of character animation and he can attest
that everything's driven by the
animation so obviously we relied a lot
on the pantomime of these characters we
didn't want them to you know speak and
and have magical properties so there was
a lot of reference to the animal kingdom
and lots of watching you know YouTube
videos and studying dogs and cats and
owls and birds and bats and but the
every technological technological
advancement was driven by a request by
the animation team it'd be really great
if we didn't have to hand animate all of
the blubber and loose skin you know and
one of this big mountainous dragon is
moving around and that would kind of
plant a seed with with the the R&D
department they would start developing
something so that lo and behold next
movie it's like hey we solved that you
know so now you can really focus on
performance you don't have to worry so
much about just dragging skin that might
be one example of it and that happened
across the board so back on the first
film we would say Wow would be so great
if the characters could just run through
this knee-high grass and like no hold on
they can only stand on rocks you know
anything that we can't interact with
environment and and now we have on this
third movie just in the background out
of focus
you'd have leaves blowing on branches
and ribbons of grass moving in the in
the wind and it's just something that
brings the world alive and
such a way that is subliminal but it's
immersive and I'll just brought into
being by kind of a wishlist of it would
be great if we could do that in the
future even if we can't do it now plus
you got to advance your beard agenda
with all of the characters which is
amazing
Brad tell us what it's like joining this
family and you know you not messing it
up thanks for that yeah well well the
it's funny I've never heard you know
experienced when you come into a team
that's worked together for a decade
there's a bunch of really cool
functional relationships and there's
also a bunch of interesting
dysfunctional relationships but I mean
that in the greatest sense of the word
it's it's really like a family that's
been together for a long time to do
these things so you know part of my job
is to you know sort of help cajole and
help really help Dean focus on what's it
mean to bring this all together because
I think a lot of creatives can relate to
you can set up a great story you can set
up some great characters in different
circumstances but to try to bring all
those to an end in this this movie had
probably the highest goal of any movie
I've worked on when you're trying to
have you want hiccup and Astrid and up
in a place where they've earned marriage
and to run this kingdom you've got to
get the place where hiccup and toothless
we really root for them to separate as
you know Dean describes that better
sweet ending which is really tough when
everybody says goodbye to the Dragons I
mean there's and then on top of that
toothless meets light fury and and you
know we all wish we had a light fury in
our lives that could bring us out of our
sort of domesticated malice you know and
sort of get into a world of aspiration
so it was really helping Dean and the
team all find this way but I mean
there's guys the every department their
heart and souls up on the screen and
they care so deeply about the movie so
to plug into that is like a true gift
well yeah I agree one of the most
emotional arcs of the movie for me is
how the light fury distrusts and does
not like hiccup at the beginning that
moving by the end she ends up saving his
life and how early in the process was
that something that you came upon it was
like from the moment you knew you wanted
to have a girlfriend for toothless or or
to how come along slowly it probably
evolved what once we decided there was
going to be a a character that would
represent the engine of change this this
character that represented for toothless
the call of the wild and naturally that
creates this dynamic where hiccup is
very reliant upon toothless he's he was
so he was it was just kind of a mess and
you could never do anything right until
toothless came into his life it's given
him confidence and it's earned him
respect within his people so hiccups
greatest fear is that toothless would go
away and he'd be exposed for the loser
that he believes himself to be so we had
to make sure that this this character
the life fairy would would not only
represent another destiny for toothless
but that it had to be done with charm
otherwise the audience would resent her
from the beginning breaking up this star
couple of hiccup and toothless and it
just seemed like there's a human in the
mix and then you have a dragon trying to
lure a dragon back into its it's kind of
natural habitat and its natural destiny
there was going to need we needed to
kind of create some kind of conflict
yeah and so having her be immediately
distrusting of hiccup and always trying
to kill him every time she sees him
painted its own ending in a way that she
should be the one that comes to his aid
at the end we only have a time for a
couple more questions so I've got some
hardball questions from my nephews
they'd literally texted me these five
minutes ago can a dragon beat an
anaconda of course seems pretty obvious
the answer and follow-up question what
about underwater very astute well as
we've seen toothless is pretty useless
underwater so it depends on what dragon
it is I would say anacondas got the
point anaconda wow that's great that's
like a draw that's really nice everybody
gets something win-win
okay real question from their uncle what
what does it take what is the secret
each one of these movies has been moving
and it made me cry or make Chris cry
because I don't cry some cool and you
know it is not simple to make a sequel
that alone to that are embraced and that
get create urgency with the audience and
get him into the theater what how did
you guys what you know what did you have
in your head that kept you on the
straight and narrow to make sure that
you weren't just repeating something you
know you were really advancing the ball
this is a very important question I
really do need to know the asking for a
friend
[Laughter]
III think for me personally we should
all respond to it but it was knowing
that we were doing sequels that had
purpose like this the second movie would
be the second act of this larger story
and we would reach a finite conclusive
end and for me getting back into the
character of hiccup in in a second
installment or a third installment meant
bringing to the party a real problem not
just some sort of superficial oh there's
a new bad guy it's like what is he going
through what stage at his life what can
we all relate to so finding a universal
crossroads is what ultimately dictated
the idea that we would age them in each
film and meet them at different points
in their lives and so for me just having
that sense of purpose gave it gave it
direction and then trying to infuse it
with things that are real to me like I
lost my dad when I was 19 so
that's what happens to hiccup and you
know all of these different you've had
your heartbroken people have died people
have moved on and these things challenge
you to become a better version of
yourself or learn from the past and
that's what I tried to bring to the
story you know they're I mean the only
thing I would add is I mean that you
know Dean's an amazing storyteller so he
thinks broadly about these things the
team is engaged in these creative
conversations so it's big part of
helping how you play those cards how you
played each of them out but I would say
that adding two new invigorating
characters new characters into the third
is really important you know effort
Abraham that did grêmio that just a joy
to work with but a great sort of
psychological villain which was fun for
movie and then you know the light again
the light for it was a great new
character I think and you know one of
the interesting sort of geeky process
things is you don't often animate full
scenes with characters that don't speak
so Dean actually in the script writes
basically lines for them and then he and
the animators sort of talked about the
intention of every shot with with an
actual sort of dialogue intention if
then of course enhanced by Randy and the
guys at Lucasfilm with the with the
track but it's a really difficult
animation process right so anyway that's
a little bit of a side note but I think
like Furies a new character as well I
just know wrapping up but I just think I
just have to hats off to the
collaboration they'll a collaborative
process of animation and Dean's you know
our great leader writer director and but
I think he was also willing to have you
know collaboration of our great team
along the way everybody had ideas of
what the movie you know things they
wanted to see I was you know ad nauseam
I was so interested in what the reign of
hiccup was going to be when he became
chief and that's kind of woven into that
and little little ideas from different
people along the way I think added up to
make the sum of the parts you know it's
also the fear like the fear of making a
bad sequel are the distance the
disappointing third installment of a
trilogy you know that's a really common
that's the title that working title and
spider-verse three yeah we're making it
first thank you guys so much I
congratulate them to these guys on this
incredible epic really deeply personal
movie thank you very much all right next
up you have to keep lapping while they
move that's right the whole time
next up as a movie from France our
sister Republic and England's X please
let us watch a clip from the very
innovative film
I lost my body
I lost my body Jeremy clapping Marc
DuPont obese
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I need a need a bigger TV that thing
holds up welcome these filmmakers from
my body oh it's so good big and loud my
word this is the best theater in the
world by the way not even a joke like
objectively speaking its famous yes
big giant screen great sound it's really
a wonderful way to see that extremely
visceral and scene where you're really
with that severed hand and rooting for a
severed hand which isn't pretty action
scene it's like the hand is Jason Bourne
yeah it's pretty amazing you know that
it started with a novel and where you
could hear the thoughts of the hand and
you can talk a little bit about how you
were able to empathize with this this
character without the use of voiceover
and and still understand what it was
going through yes I mean in the book the
film is based on the book and it was the
hand was telling the story of his common
life with no fair and so at the
beginning we think why I was thinking
that to be good to have a voiceover
because it will be simple also does a
lot of things but in fact it kills the
point of view perspective of the film
because the film is really more than a
story I wanted something like to bring
you a new experience to the audience and
to start the movie with being involved
in a new character I'm not a human but a
part of a human a piece of a body and
when the hand was talking in the same
time the hand was doing
whether we were in the point of it was
not working it was killing the point of
view in fact it was really pushing the
audience and the audience at this moment
was only me and my producer did the hand
have a very silly voice like a
high-pitched in fact we know we did it
get so further because the voice was
only like your subtitles maybe and I was
thinking about which kind of voice but
we we did we give up sooner so and when
you decided to not use voice over you
have to fund find something I would tell
story how to make people believe on the
hand how you give in Patti so you have
to to trust the weakness and you have
the hand which is in a silent world and
you have to make this witness strange
and so you can use cinema for that as
you have to bring some soil eg you have
to develop a new kind of way to frame or
to ear when you are hand how you heal
the world it's strange to say that but
you have to to find this kind of
solution in cinema and I think the
experience is is a stronger when you use
all these kind of tricks with sane
cinema to to make the film a really new
way to experiment life to be to discover
also story and so yes we have also to
use a lot of music to be able to follow
the ham and to build like emotional
transition between all these timelines
and yes it was really exciting for a
director to to have this kind of piece
of body this is a very exciting movie as
a director it's terrifying as a producer
tell me are you a maniac
tell us the story of how you came to
support this movie and what it took to
get it on the screen seven years so if
I'm not wrong yeah well I I've done many
different things you know from
live-action television and feature film
from television you know in in in series
for animation etc so what I love is
navigate from one language to another
and try to explore different way of
doing thing and I've done a lot of
nonverbal material in my years of
animation you know always was fascinated
by the the power of nonverbal because
somehow it forces you to invent a
language that is far more Universal than
the words so when I read that book I
really found that unique opportunity
that that we both - both of them would
be very challenged and we both know to
challenge in this in this story is one
is the fact that you have to incarnate a
character that doesn't speak obviously
and the other one was how much can you
push the language of cinema to have a
audience caring for characters that only
have five fingers to express itself so
yeah somehow you can say I'm a maniac
let's talk about the ending spoiler
alert yeah if you haven't seen the
movies shame here I mean shame this is
on you yep my mother
yes sexted and would like you to explain
the entire ending I also a very lively
debate with my extended family after we
watched it about what it meant and
whether it was about you know moving on
from loss going forward and not being
trapped in the past and the big question
that came out of it for us
was whether the hand was supposed to be
real or a metaphor and
whether new phil was ever subconsciously
aware of their brief reuniting or not
when he was sleeping so answer yeah
please
that's a compound or both of our
families it's very high difficulty but I
would say it was really hard for me as
director storyteller to to tell this
this handing to my producer and to show
something okay was mainly in my head
because I know my producer has to convey
so also people too so it was really hard
and it happened I think we agreed on the
same and only at the end end of the film
like a few days before the end and but
my producer speak very well of the hand
because I have to explain so so many
times and he speak better English than
me and if you say something wrong I will
correct good wow that's a good way to be
you just that's called cherry-picking in
American basketball so mark passing on
the responsibility on me reminds me of
something now basically you have three
three stories to hand one is the hand
trying to reach his body one is the love
affair and what is the quest of never
felt for himself so we were debating of
how do we have to mix all of those three
do we find like the big ending that's
all of those three things or do we have
to privilege with one another the thing
is the the law of storage you should not
mix the effect and the consequence the
love story is not
the purpose it's the spark that gives
now sell the courage to try and defy
destiny but it's not the condition of
him of a coming destiny the very
important thing is for now fell to face
his past and overcome his past it's the
quest for himself in this leap of faith
that the condition for him to be able so
the law of story would not be possible
for that so he has to achieve that's he
has to reunite with himself he has to
find his wholeness again before he can
actually achieve so if we would have
ended the story with the law of story
that would be to narrowing the the
journey of Sderot fell and as for the
end it was kind of difficult because
we've been very cautious all over the
film to never give a clue to the
audience whether this was real or not if
you think about it all of the witnesses
have seen the ham there baby you know
there is this young boy there's drunk
man and the blind man astronaut the dead
pigeons tell no tales I was a working
title so it's very much open for
interpretation obviously the hand
incarnates the memory incarnate the
broken part of now failed in his attempt
and as you see there in the film there
is a very brief glimpse moment where the
getting reunited in the dream or in the
reality of now fell and that opens
something completely different and
somehow the hand vanishes because now
fell is reunited with himself and the
hand incarnated the separation so there
is no purpose for the hand to exist
anymore I had that answer exactly
and I chose what I wanted to say and
it's funny because I was I was fighting
for this end and now it's any mark told
me okay you have to assume this him and
now is the guy who explained him well
that's what what a producer does he
challenged the director and the writer
to understand what is the purpose of his
story so Jeremy how did you achieve this
animation style like what were your
references and did you have a mood board
or anything like that how did you how
did you come upon this look first I'd
wanted something that clean very because
it was I wanted something about drawing
it's about a hand but humanity but human
and I wanted yes to be able to put soul
into into a character into the character
of the hand and I wanted also this kind
of accident that line the film is about
accident and so we have a little low
budget not a big budget for this film
and like 200 million oh my god a bit
more she won 175 less than 5 millions
and and my reference was it's a movie
for me and I was thinking but Ralph
Bakshi American pop or maybe people know
him but ish Colleen who made drink jam
is a shot filmmaker but it's really
drawing and without any desire to make
the thing as not aesthetical but nice
looking I mean and so this was my
purpose on the film and also because we
are experimented not only story but also
a town of Paris the town of Paris for
French angle I wanted to be the town is
on the pavement I wanted to to put
poetry into something not really nice
but maybe it's stronger when you succeed
to put a tree in those kind of area
which is not
which doesn't allow usually to have
poetry like the suburbs like very urban
things intercom everything I think it's
stronger when you you you you can do
that and it's Apfel when you have the
music to do that to raise all this this
city great city to something a more
colorful and more cosmic mystical so the
style was about this starting from very
you know this is a piece of her body
this is not very nice nice looking her
hand severed hand and I didn't wanted to
make it nice looking it has to be truth
and drawing L post would also the
animation help us to bring distance and
to not be too much go as live-action
tempest to live action and so it was a
solution for me to not be too lovely too
nice and but also acceptable for
audience to to be engaged in this kind
of poetry quite a trip right like
beautiful drawings about uncomfortable
things you know we only time for one
more question which was going to be do
you have Roger Deakins email but if we
can't you can give it to us Baxter
that's fine
somebody please I'm not sure which one I
have so many questions for you guys I
thought there was gonna be the green
cards you know like I'm the talk shows
right you can just do this sort of thing
yeah okay I want ask one more story
question because can we talk a little
about the fly and and what that
represents for you guys Heskey fly nine
here we go yes
so was the fly was not on the book in
fact and but the book the story was
about destiny and I wanted in the book
the hand was talking about destiny and
it was through world the world but I
wanted this team to be and something to
incarnate destiny in the movie and I
thought fly was a good symbol for that
because it's something we all want to
grab which
that easy we fail most of time and the
fly can see everywhere and so the fly
was a building the kind of foundation of
the story and each time there is a not a
talking about point but a meeting point
now fell and it's destiny the fly is
involved into in this congratulate is
incredible gentlemen on a very Regis
movie thank you guys so much
[Applause]
guys we yet we wrote a bit Chris
reminded me oh here we go here we go la
próxima clip - de una película model
Alania sobre un hombre que tiene que vea
her a Scandinavia what was a you know
say in a tape wavelet Oh Fria encuentra
santa clauss es uno de la película my
original Adele ano in gran or Gullo para
new at Romeo sergio la production the
Netflix que se llaman Klaus Chris do you
mind translating that real fast sure
this next clip is from close
Klaus Sergio Pablo's Gingka goat oh and
Marissa Roman only good children get
toys dear mr. Klaus I shoveled all the
yards on my street today that's good
right
please don't put me on the naughty list
here mr. Klaus today me and my brothers
helped mom at the Troy we'll do this
every day if you bring us some toy
monastic class our neighbor was fixing
up the hole in the fence today and then
he fell and he hurt his leg it must have
really really hurt because he did not
stop screaming so he hoped him he said
he didn't like it but deep down I think
he did and yesterday instead of stealing
mrs. RunAs berries we picked them all
for her she came to our house later and
she brought mom lots of berry jam
and then mom brought her a berry pie
dear mr. louse
I've been going to class every day and I
always do my homework
[Music]
miss Alva is the best teacher ever
also I clean my dad's old clarinet I
hope I did a good job he seemed happy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I think it's time we send that postman a
message you know what to do
pumpkin did you know that arson is down
70 percent it's true when's the last
time you saw a house burnt down
precisely the cookouts swap meets and
yeah I don't know it's like everyone's
gone mad or something
a true selfless act always sparks
another well look who's suddenly a
chatterbox tell me what made you
squander all those words into that
nugget of wisdom oh just something
someone used to say well let me tell you
something
I've been around long enough to know
that everyone is out to get something
those kids those kids are in it for the
toys and the grown-ups yeah that well I
don't know what they're after but sure
is not goodwill and peace on earth what
about you what's in it for you me well
you know it's different I don't look out
[Music]
[Music]
sanyo Gingka come on up here guys give
him a big round of applause guys forgive
my Island accent my gosh guys that is so
great so funny the way those reindeer
sliding around on their bums at the end
destroys me every time
tell us about you're making a movie like
this in Madrid well I mean I we left
these knee - I think it was and the
reason why we we got no experience and
we always wanted to go back home raise a
family have children close to the
grandparents and by doing that I knew
the road to make a film that was
relevant was gonna be a lot harder you
know them being in LA so well and also
it was a change of profession for me you
know going from being a 2d animator to
now trying to become a storyteller so I
set myself up for a long road just
learning the ropes of storytelling and I
knew that wasn't gonna be a lot of
failure involved and I embraced it and
over the years we you know tried and
fail and adjusted and failed again and
adjusted and we kept doing that until
you know we started understanding what
we were doing sounds like filmmaking
hate us yeah I should try that something
yeah you try it it's great you know you
started at Disney and you were sort of
legendarily you know with the most
talented animator your class at CalArts
from that's what other people who are
your classmates told us we're very young
we wouldn't know right that's 95 I'm
just a kid
but but this movie feels like it is both
innovative and looking forward and also
an O Maj system of like the early
classic
animation from the the early days of
Disney that amongst the legends that you
worked with like tell me well what was
your influence and how and how did you
balance those two things well I mean a
lot of it was my love for traditional
and and my refuse to accept the reasons
that I was given for why we should not
do it anymore
you know and and but I also I got the
witness Disney trying to bring back to
the at certain point and I I saw that
their approach was to just call
nostalgia alone and I very clearly to me
that showed that's not enough that's
just we used to strive to better in the
medium with every film when I was at
Disney and somehow at some point we said
let's stop looking forward let's start
looking backwards and I thought it was a
mistake so I said okay so whatever we
left off you know we should pick it up
and we should look at all the
developments in technology and art that
happened in the last 15 years or 20
years and see what we can do to demolish
some of the barriers that traditional
animation I've had and make a
contribution and the tagline was always
we're not bringing to the back we're
bringing it forward and take that writer
yeah and and talked about some of the
innovation I feel like the shading in
this movie was was a real innovative
development or so talked a little bit
about some of the choices you made for
the look of this film that has a sort of
2d 3d feeling to it like what to build a
pipeline to make something that hadn't
been made before a lot of weight had to
do with dealing with the uncertainty or
like once you set the goal okay one
thing we should try to improve is the
use of light and the integration of a
characters and backgrounds that's
usually you know an obstacle for 2d
animation so let's tackle that making
that decision is one thing but knowing
whether or not you're gonna put time and
resources into it and actually succeed
at it it's very different so but I was
lucky enough to have incredible
production designers who were the ones
that came up with the formula and then
later on partner up with the guys that
living in the personal
who brought the amazing tools that made
it workable for our production but the
uncertainty of not knowing like how do
you budget something that doesn't exist
how do you how do you you know call out
for employment like we're looking for
lighters and people are like what is
that into the like I can't tell you
really because it involves proprietary
stuff but would you work for us anyways
right so so how do you guys yeah how do
you budget something that doesn't exist
say we had so many people budgeting this
movie and we crashed hominid cells
machines doing this because we're like
okay the most computing power or 2x1 to
excel on the excel yeah usually you
crash the avid but not on this picture
so I think you know we talked about the
process in the type of talent we needed
and I think that's work came down to us
okay this talent doesn't exist we're
gonna have to train them and so he was
really finding the best they were just
waiters that you met in a sangria bar as
you were saying I mean Sergio call a lot
of people you know and we did a lot of
recruitment we did recruitment online we
went to honesty and did some recruitment
there so most of the talent in this
movie were very young and we had to
train them we had to train the cleanup
department right because he was a to t
you know pipeline up the big question
was whatever this tool is do we do we
make a tool for technicians to work or
for artists to work but you know and
then we realized the best way to do this
was to use people who already knew how
to paint light and so a lot of our
lighting department were extremely
talented visual development artist
concert parties who are very used to
working in the illustration photo shop
and we just basically gave them the tool
that they get to use what they always do
in Photoshop but they can apply that to
moving images the the training period
for these guys was two weeks and they
were going well you know I'm the great
thing about it is that if you make a
tool for artists the same you
perfection they have been a part of the
nature of tradition emission travels all
the way through to them because you
could give the same shot to two
different lighters and they would make
different calls you know and it becomes
an artistic choice I think that's what
gives that organic quality that we don't
see in cz films it finds yeah Cheers so
interesting is your your your train your
teaching the techniques that you learned
as a student to young animators now in a
way that that is really like passing on
a certain you know aesthetic and a style
and an approach to movement telling a
story through movement that is like
gonna have a really lasting impression
you trained all those people now you've
you know the cats out of the bag they're
gonna go make their own things to that
easy I have to say we train a good
portion of our team but I was lucky
enough to work with some extremely
talented people in every department and
I always made a point to be very aware
of where I'm weak at and surround myself
with people far stronger than mean those
theories and listen to them and without
that philosophy that movie couldn't have
happened ginko you are a big promoter of
diversity in in animation and you are
one of the founders of women in
animation what are some simple things we
can do yeah some of the things we all
can do to be better and make animation
better than it is well I'm really really
proud first of all you know we always
looked for the best talent on this movie
and we made a movie made a point I'm not
tallying the numbers until the very end
and at the very end we tally the numbers
and what the data represented was 22
different countries 15 languages and 43%
of our 300-plus crew or women
but you know find the best talent was
always the priority so you know Sir Joe
and all the department heads look for
the very best talent Gabe didn't ask
gave him training and you know there's a
lot of women's study animation in most
schools around the world over sixty
percent of the students are women so we
aren't we can't be that pipeline you
know we've got to find that talent feed
that pipeline and you know we all know
animation movies take a long time so you
know hopefully in 10-15 years we're
gonna see these women they're getting us
going out going to leadership what
you're saying is there's no excuse that
is correct and what's great about having
all this diversity is that it allows for
different types of stories to be told
right nothing against the white boys
that have been telling great stories
we're great we're great you know you can
be good I think there are different
types of stories there we go CIL's well
that's one of the interesting things to
me so if a friend of ours was it makes a
lot of all this is TV shows and movies
they make them in the south and they
grew up there and one of the things he
said is if what if all the music just
came from Los Angeles like the whole
world's music right it's like it's so
great that music comes from all over the
world like that that there's a you know
there's like a Johannesburg sound that's
different than the Atlanta sound and
what I think is so interesting and I
want and I'm curious about is what is it
what is it like making a movie in a
completely different city and how did it
affect the storytelling yeah sure I mean
we really had a very international crew
I mean Sergio is from Spain our two
production designers are from Poland our
supervisor for light scene is from
France I think that it enriches the
movie I mean it was very enriching for
surgery as well because you know each
culture each language its nationality
brings their own energy to the movie so
for us it was fantastic it was really
you know a blessing but also I mean it's
I think I think the handicap of this
movie was really our strength as well
when you look at it I mean we had so
little time to make this movie and
surgeon tells us because we said ok once
we put this movie up on reels we gotta
start you know lay out and we're still
recruiting Marisa was busy trying to
build studio yeah I didn't not tell me
about you know we were like 40 people
are the smallest studio in the very hard
you know of him at RIT and then three
months later in the middle of them
summer time when in August you know now
that I was in Spain he's like oh we're
gonna let grow up up to 300 people he's
like oopsy-daisy so I don't feel that
you know we can all fit in this studio
so in less than three months you know we
have to literally remodel the studio get
everything ready
buy the equipment so it work visas all
that stuff I mean versus credit she
closed she closed the old facility on a
Friday and we started on Monday new
facility flawless and busting laws crew
fun the center of town but he was a team
effort
I was not the only one working there at
that time so was there any language
barriers from people we decided to speak
in English like a secret meeting in
Spanish if there's no you know the funny
thing was like I it was so rarely we
would have meetings where they would
meet all Spanish speakers but there was
always like there was like superior
power that made
there's gotta be that one guy who we
have all speak English for course one
Swedish guy Sven I know him he's a bully
about English are we got time for one
last question you want to I yeah I have
one here
do you have Alamo levar's email
I want Antonio's Oh even better guys
thank these incredible filmmakers
beautiful film thank you guys so much
[Applause]
oh yeah the luncheon what was the the
ham budget that's the one I forgot to
ask the line item for the ham beard
meets so much ham so many grapes this
next clip is missing
oh no link miss thang I'm sorry it's a
beautiful beautiful film full of amazing
craftsmanship check out this clip from
missing link
missing link Chris Butler Ariane sutnar
and Travis Knight
[Music]
[Music]
who is it that comes before us Sir
Lionel Frost and if I might ask how the
devil can you speak English so well how
can you speak English so well
well Eton obviously how do you know I'm
not speaking Yeti because look I'm not
sure exactly where this is taking us is
there anything wrong with staying
exactly where we are do you always speak
in questions I don't know do i I have a
question for you
why did you guide us here at the tip of
the spear we do not wield weapons to
threaten but to defend that doesn't make
them any less sharp you speak with some
wisdom I state the obvious often that is
the same thing well here is an absolute
we do not seek glory or riches we're not
here to pillage your temple or disturb
your tranquility we want nothing from
you then why are you here
that is me sorry the country cousin the
redneck actually yeah actually it's more
of a rust isn't it people say red I find
that more of an Auburn have a lot of
autumn in me a lot of autumn colors so
you know anyway I figured maybe there
was a place for me here among you come
this way
[Music]
this is shangri-la myth mail arena
shangri-la that is not our name we call
it our flag matter what does it mean
keep out we hate you
this valley is unsullied precious and so
it shall remain there is no place for
you among us but you're my kind of
affair my family no I think not
it seems to me you did not have to
travel halfway around the world to find
your kind man killer of life of hope of
dreams man talks of the magic of the
world but it is a prize something to be
claimed as proof of his words I mean she
has a point these secrets you have seen
they are ours and ours alone
the outside world must never learn the
truths of our sacred Valley that is
something we cannot allow she's gonna
kill us kill you monsters oh oh gosh for
a minute there I thought just for a
second that maybe you would go throw
them into the inescapable pit of
isolation and miserable disappointment
Oh Jerri what there you will spend the
rest of your lives
pondering your ill transgression
you can't keep us here it's popper
it is preservation
yes please welcome Chris and Ariane how
are you oh my gosh that was so beautiful
[Applause]
what a gorgeous movie Lord alive it's
funny - it's not fair there can only be
one what but what do you think it is
about stop-motion that has such enduring
charm and what is it about putting your
hands on a film and every frame of that
film that makes you approach filmmaking
differently we talk a lot about this and
I think for me ultimately it comes down
to real light on real objects and I
think there is something magical about
seeing an object on screen brought to
life because I think it takes us back to
our childhood when we're playing with
toys and we're imagining them coming to
life I think there is an element of that
I think what we've been doing at the
studio is we're continuing to refine the
medium we're continuing to push it so
maybe you can't see the edges quite so
much now but there's still that kind of
chaotic element of real light on real
objects there is an imperfection to it
I've said in the past you know like if
you think about a handmade costume with
all the you know the fuzz on it and the
hand stitching there is something
beautifully imperfect about that the CG
guys are spending millions of dollars
trying to emulate that and we get it for
free well not free sorry
yeah not entirely very much not free
yeah what was the fur but that's not
talking now sir good we're done here we
know we can we can let our hair about
well into the tens of dollars I believe
it what of the I mean of your talking
about the way and like has led the
charge on the technical innovations and
refined
in this medium what what as a filmmaker
as filmmakers what is the that what part
of that has been the most valuable I
mean this is your second movie at the
studio and and ParaNorman the first one
really a wonderful film and you know
what we're also worked on them on Kubo
right which was another amazing
fantastic film we could literally just
say you're in named movies that are
great from this studio and just keep
clapping it is true yeah but I mean and
we're just even watching that clip in
and knowing how hard it was to move her
sessioning fur as she was walking around
and how beautiful that was knowing that
someone was doing that by hand there's
something about knowing that each frame
of that was it was lovingly done that
makes it even all the more spectacular
that's not really question it's more of
a statement it's hard for us to talk
about that because it was painful I'll
bet no heard that watching her and I
loved her performance and I think she
came out great but that was a little
miniature you know nightmare trying to
get all that fur to work well it is a
nightmare that became a dream come on
how did when did you know that you had
found the soul of this movie along the
process I think it was so originally I
had a story about this world's first
cryptozoologists so Lionel Frost and it
was a completely different story and I
think he and that one he was chasing
unicorns but it was his story it was
about this flawed who's laughing at
unicorns so that's a valid creature to
miss you got chasing unicorns is the
title of our autobiography so there was
this other story and it was about this
flawed hero who learns to be a better
person and I can Dov was working on that
for a while and they came up with a
different idea of a Bigfoot who wants to
find his family in the Himalayas and I
kind of mush them together and I think
link is the heart of this story for me
this story was always about identity and
your identity is something that you
choose it's not something that's put
upon you and that really came to life
with links predicament it's so
interesting he seems like he's prepared
for a different movie than everyone else
and they're all trying to have this epic
adventure and he's like he's like not
quite he doesn't quite fit in you want
to talk about like Zach and that
characterization and the counterpoint
between him and the rest of the picture
well that that was key to the casting of
that character I wanted Zach right from
the get-go that Galifianakis talented
person because the his brand of comedy
is entirely that it's about displacement
it's about being the most awkward person
in the room and that's him yeah but I
think what I wasn't quite prepared for
was that when he was doing the
recordings just how how soulful it was
there is a vulnerability and a naivety
to this character that I find really
touching and that that was I think when
the movie really started to work
properly for me because he wasn't just a
buffoon he wasn't just a bumbling
sidekick he was a you know a real living
breathing character that's exactly how I
felt too and it's the vulnerability
you're saying and I think also when you
kind of worked on Chris really worked on
these moments between Sir Lionel and
Link or Susan and when he didn't shy
away from that but really like a loud
space when you see the movie a lot
they're really like looking at each
other with love and I felt like that was
really helping the movie work too
besides what we wanted was a big action
adventure was going to they were going
all over the world on this quest but
it's those like little moments and he
really allowed that to have space and
insisted on and I felt like that was
kind of that that made the movie work
for me was it later in the process when
you guys started to find those space to
do those romance Chris what's a man I
mean we put cement the thing is it's
when you put them in you know you guys
know storyboarding you would put them in
the
everything gets different once you shoot
the shots and once you have a little bit
of other people weighing in on what they
want and how you know maybe how quickly
you know the first act should go or
whatever that's not the case actually
with us at all but it is you do have to
fight I think over this you know that
takes so long it's like five years to
get it done so in that space of time if
you relinquish a little bit of that
control and ease off then you don't get
to have those little moments but aches a
long time to stick with them we we find
that that it becomes way too late in our
personal process that you you go and
going like people gonna love this move
it's gonna be funny it's gonna have this
cool background and like there's all
these great characters and then you
realize nothing matters
that person goes like you know you did a
great job back there and then something
the whole movie comes to life yeah like
why are we so stupid
welfare is a talking point yeah why are
we supposed to why are we so why yeah
Chris specifically it's my a my
everybody let's just talk for a few
minutes about why I am so stupid no no
me now this Miller Chris not this Chris
oh I'm a Chris's this guy's a genius
like it seems like the inmates run the
asylum and and so Eroica what are some
of the advantages and also challenges of
having an artist run company no talking
points people I'm the worst
so this is good what is bad about that
Adventure Challenge analysis there's no
judgement in that that's a producer
that's a positive a challenge
who doesn't love a challenge I think you
know we have it's it's like it any kind
of when you put we have as a head of our
departments we have these artists who've
been working on the
what they do for a long time and with
each other so we come up with incredible
innovation but we also put them in
charge of working with the team of
people and sometimes you know you know
that too
that's not always your strengths right
so you can have the inmates you know
struggling with that you can you can
have sometimes a producer who should
know better
instead encouraging them and wasting
money on only one shot because we really
care about it and it's a stir it's I
think it's it's we marched to the beat
of our own drummer I couldn't be I mean
honestly I'm seeing a downside I mean
the work speaks for itself obviously
because I'm crazy tell me a time when
you got because everybody does we really
do when you felt like really lost in the
weeds or like a wrong turn that you took
in the story that you final a cul-de-sac
or something that you go like oh and a
real forehead slapper or something that
you figure to frame it more positively
something that you know you figured out
like somewhere in the middle of the
movie that unlocked it for you guys to
be honest there was a lot of stuff at
the beginning not so much the middle but
in the storyboarding process because I
think part of what Ariane was saying is
that there is I've got always been given
so much support creatively like I'm not
often told no and because and because
this is film five and each time we make
one of these we're pushing the
technological boundaries of what we can
achieve so when it came time for me to
write the script for this I was just
like great I can write anything I want
and they won't say no and at times when
I was right and I was thinking should I
write this
and then I'd do it anyway but then it's
on me because I was the the head of the
story department so it's on me to then
realize that so I'm the first person
who's who's sitting there looking at
like this three hour movie with 600
locations that all have to be hand built
and so there was a lot of pruning early
on and I think we have to we have to be
really careful about that because we're
building the assets while we're working
on the story so I have to be really
upfront about those those decisions of
what what what to take out really early
because we can't afford to build a
location and then not use it and I think
it's really important when you have the
person who's in really his movie making
the decisions about what to cut and how
to solve some of these problems it
always comes out you know more graceful
and it comes out a lot better when he's
part of that rather than saying nope
you're just gonna end up get rid of that
that and that and it becomes like a you
know a hodgepodge well what's
interesting is the physical realities of
production and shooting and moving these
puppets around it creates the rigor
right that's the that's the thumb
pressing on you it's gravity we and it's
created Stokes creativity that that was
that was probably one of the most
difficult things was let's call it a
problem with one of our actors I don't
mean our real actors I mean the puppets
so mister link was our most incredibly
complex puppet individual yeah I mean
well when I designed him that drawing
that I originally did many years ago has
become known as the Harry avacado
drawing because he's basically a circle
with legs you know and that turns out to
be the most complicated puppet you could
ever build because there's no neck no
shoulders he's covered in hair and all
these things
the team was figuring out but figuring
it out and we need to shoot so our
puppet with you know they're just about
getting to set on time sometimes they're
not and so you find yourself in a
situation like the bar brawl where
I've got so many puppets and not all of
them are available at the same time so I
have to having to shoot part of it on
green-screen over here six months later
we're shooting another part you're
trying to make the light and consistent
so that kind of thing that the the
practical issues that you can't really
plan for that was probably the most
difficult thing you were saying rigor
and even though we're joking around and
we're crazy we really do have a lot of
we are rigorous we're rigorous with we
make the movie once or twice with
storyboards and we're not you know we we
can't shoot anything and cut it out like
if we're shooting it we don't resuit
anything really I mean we do of course
but that's not the goal so in fact we
are pretty disciplined in terms of
making it and you know we want to know I
want to know what your third act how
that's going to end just because we have
to in order to be able to have time to
to build it all and create at all and I
wish we yeah that was a I think what
Chris was alluding to is like as if you
if you had your leading man if you had
you know he Lord yeah I'm sure he can
bleep like sorry
they're like you said he's coming to set
he's definitely gonna be there you know
just shoot around him oh yeah your main
character of this movie he'll be there
but it's like months are going by and
you're like is he dead what what how are
we doing this so that's those are the
kinds of things that we contended with
on this which made it you know more
challenging and we're speaking freely
because our crews not here when they're
here and we say that they're heartbroken
so so if you bump into them don't repeat
the story just keep this between us and
right buddy thank you guys so much for
all you've done to medium forward it's a
wonderful film and I hope you're very
proud yeah
[Applause]
this next movies will be one glass I
think that's a dollar ninety-nine well
you just give it to us at the door the
next clip is from a movie
from an independent studio in a small
town north of San Francisco here is a
clip from the marvelous Toy Story 4
[Applause]
Toy Story for Josh Cooley mark Nielsen
and Jonas Rivera
[Music]
hello mr. cowboy how are you today
[Music]
[Music]
huh I mean awfully crazy that you hide
you not to drive so fast you almost ran
him over
[Music]
if it isn't Bobby
Gus Lefty
billy goat and gruff right right right
sorry guys girls girls of course
right okay let's get a look at you you
need any repairs no hey nice fine girl
where did you get all this stuff here
and there you know some kids play
rougher than others so I try to be
prepared how long have you been out on
your own seven fantastic years seven you
would not believe the things I see and
no gig yo come on out there's someone I
want you to meet what's the situation
we heading out of town no way
[Laughter]
I'm totally staring woody this is giggle
mcdhh Impuls officer giggle mcdhh impuls
I run pet patrol from Minneapolis
yes search and rescue combat girl just
heard there's a birthday party at the
playground on Main Street rumor has it
they got to pinata that should be 20 to
30 kids oh yeah
combat Carl's gettin played with you
guys in you but no I can't sir
oh I need to get back to my kid what you
got a kid yeah way to beat the odds
soldier beat you at the playground beep
combat Carl's got a beam you out a party
to crash all right it's not Andy no no
no he went off to college but he gave us
to Bonnie no yeah yeah it's why I'm out
here for other toy is trapped in this
antique store and I have enchants
antiques we know that store that's great
that is great if you know the store you
could really help me follow away we
wasted years they're just sitting on the
Shelf collecting dust
Oh beau that's awful but I don't have a
choice I have to get that toy from Gabby
Wow
you're clear that weirdo if I were you
I'd cut my losses and go home
but Bonnie needs him to get through
kindergarten kids lose toys every day
Bonnie he'll get over it
no no but what you see you see Bonnie
needs him just like Molly needed you
know sorry girls Molly's not here Molly
oh I don't know kid that was a long time
ago
Oh Bo's kid was something special she
was the cutest thing but so afraid of
the dark it was just a phase oh you
weren't there in the beginning
hearing Molly crying Ike it broke every
toys heart
beau came into the room her lamp was the
only thing that made Molly feel safe mom
would let her keep bought one all night
and Molly would fall asleep with her
hand resting on both okay well my kid
really needs this toy will you help me
for old times sake all right all right
[Music]
gentlemen please welcome Josh Cooley
Marc Nielsen and Jonas Rivera hello
first time seeing it guys the there is
there were things I didn't notice the
the drama of the snow Ranger yeah
poor Carl heartbreaking you know what's
funny about that I don't know if you
guys stayed to the very very end after
the credits he does get his high five
eventually it's the very last frame of
the film which I love is it goes to
black right after that but the crew what
that wasn't in there for a long time the
crew was really upset closure for Carl
and at one point remember saying like
look life doesn't not everybody gets
their high five okay yeah and then I
just softened up the most relatable gag
for some reason no way high five oh my
gosh
my first question I've so many questions
for you guys the first question is who
came up with four key and why couldn't
it have been us because it's character
well four key came out of we're in a
story session one day and we were
talking about the rules of the Toy Story
world and just what it means to be in
what that movie means that you know to
your toy you when your kid leaves you
come to life we're just trying to break
it down to like the very fundamentals of
Toy Story and as a story team does we
just start pulling the threads on stuff
and you start questioning life and
everything and so somebody said well
what if she plays with a rock does that
mean the Little Rock's alive and I was
like two months lost yeah probably
and fight but we we started kind of
laughing at that because that's what our
kids do right they'll pick up anything
and play with it and they'll mix of his
school to it so we thought why not
embrace that with what would happen and
the very first thing that was drums a
spork like there was never any other
sport it's just funny and so sparkly
that it's also they're all over the
cafeteria everywhere and then it the
thing that really cracked me up was
having a character come to life
basically like if you were just dropped
on an alien planet you had no idea
what's going on and you're also like the
god of this child that's like worshiping
you but this character has never seen
Toy Story 1 2 or 3 so it has no idea
what the rules of the world are and
being a fourth film the audience is
bringing all that with them they've all
know the rules so it was a really fun
way to have a character just completely
turn everything on it's here so that was
the first thing and then the second
thing was it became an opportunity for
woody to explain his worldview what it
means to be a toy to put it to try and
put it on to this other character so we
really had a nice way to get Woody's
point of view out there we also thought
it was pretty funny
as an idea just to go further with it
this is when you're you know kid opens a
president Christmas or birthday and they
play with the box sometimes more than
the toy which is sort of a truth of
being a kid something we've watched our
kids do but we thought that how
insulting would that be if you were that
toy you know if you it's the worst thing
that could happen
garbage so it just became a way to
really amplify the stakes for poor woody
and everybody else he became a lot of
fun and Tony Hale you got I mean that
guy Tony Hale is incredible just bring
such a beautiful insecurity to that
character yeah he's so funny and he's so
warm and kind yeah you know he said got
the whole package that guy the one thing
I think is amazing about this film is
that it's very funny throughout but also
is super emotional and and I thought
that the choice to have more spoilers if
you haven't seen this movie what's wrong
with you haven't seen any of them
watching the Bruce was very confused I
sort of caught up the choice to have it
be sort of the end of Woody's story with
the gang was was a really I think a
really smart one and at what point did
that come on in the story and and
did you know that that was the right
choice it came I want to say maybe
halfway yeah we didn't have that and I
think without that we had a lot of fun
but we didn't have the story to have a
movie and it wasn't until that point
when I was like okay now there's a
reason for this film to exist like
there's a there's an arc to Woody's
character actually starts in the first
film and we were concluding it here in
the fourth one but it was a hard it was
we remember a couple times we're looking
at each other going like are we really
doing this are we trying are we trying
this and so that one tweet once we
realize like that should be the movie it
was how do we execute that in a way that
isn't burned was there resistance is
it's really brave I think there wasn't
necessarily only internally I think just
us questioning like it's a big deal to
end it like we sort of dab it like is
this we didn't want to just make another
chapter I think when we kind of started
talking about it out loud in the story
room with this idea of if if toy stories
about woody I mean we we heard a lot
about it when we first started what
people would say why are you doing doing
it because the third was such a great
ending you know even my family asked me
that and that's what they said after
Tokyo Drift yeah exactly right look at
it it's laughing now man
but it was Andrew Stanton who you're
Andrew you know wrote on the first one
and was sort of one of the godparents of
all all the toy stories he almost read
face it no no no he never saw the third
as the end he said the third is is the
end of Andy's story but toy stories
about woody Woody's the protagonist we
had this I remember this conversation
about escalating stakes this is what I
thought was interesting it's like Toy
Story all the movies present woody a
really tough problem but they're all
solvable until you get to the third the
first one he you know he gets lost but
you can get found you know in the second
one he breaks but you can get fixed and
the third one it's unsolvable your kid
grows up there's nothing you can do
about it but yet he lands on his feet
and and it's still woody and gets the
second chance so that gave us this
foothold like well what do you do like
what if you got a second chance how
would you reinvent yourself what is the
next chapter beyond that and if Buzz
Lightyear is the thing that
catapults a story into into being him
coming into what he's life in the
logical way to end it as they would
separate and I just felt us just kicking
that around in story feel heavy enough
and felt movie worthy to us like if
we're gonna do it let's do it
yeah and earlier versions of the film
you know we had what he ended up going
back with Bonnie to Bonnie's room and it
just never felt like he had been through
a real change the other adventure yeah
it was just another adventure we knew he
had to experience real change and and it
had to manifest itself in the decisions
he made at the very end it's amazing
what I love about your studio is that it
starts with outrageous risks it's easy
for us to like make a joke about how
successful you've been it but in truth
it's like started with a real punk rock
idea of like let's make on the cheap the
thing that no one's ever made a CG
animated feature and let's make it about
you know a cowboy who who's who's trying
to make up for the attempted murder of
Buzz Lightyear now he's on the lam I
guess I mean you yeah Jonas you started
on the first Toy Story as an intern and
you've grown all the way through I mean
what do you guys all think is the secret
of Pixar's enduring success i I did I
was very lucky and I want to thank
Bonnie Arnold who fellow nominee who
hired me as a tenth I suppose one boy
stars one so Thank You Bonnie and part
part of that is I think what you just
said there there Pixar's obviously a lot
different now than it was in 1994 but
there still is a little bit of a punk
rock Garage Band spirit of kind of
throwing the ball the other I mean we
you know Steve Jobs used to roam the
halls and think different and all that
attitude soaked into to everybody there
so there still although the scale and
it's it's with Disney and all that we're
proud of everything there still is a
little bit of a
a rogue group feel that we get to kind
of play on our own rules and and and
tell our own stories and I think we're
sort of I think we're sort of we sort of
all feel that still we still sort of
protect it a little bit you know I think
we're also allowed to fail and fail
quick quickly and as soon as possible
because the quicker you can fail the and
and no joke the move that's what I'm
working on these movies they're garbage
for a long time and then that is such a
relief
I'm not joking I'm sure like they really
it's like oh my gosh you know and then
we you have to just start over you know
and we do I mean how many times we did
twice three or four ten times there's at
least ten versions of a Hannah let's
tell us describe the worst one no thanks
no but one one cool thing about this
crew the makeup of our crew because
again it's been 25 years of these films
at the studio is we had people on the
career that had been part of the first
one they were part of the first crew and
then we had people animating shots with
woody that like the first movie they saw
as like a three year old child was Toy
Story and it was oh it was a blend of
both both generations coming together on
this film and that's that's something
that's unique that you don't get the
chance to be a part of very often was
pretty special about this one
yeah the younger people almost tended
the the people that their first movie
was seeing Toy Story 2 or something they
were almost more protective of it than
we were you know they had this attitude
of you we had we I guess we shared a
fear of like we can't mess up Toy Story
and their attitude was you're not gonna
mess up my childhood you know and to get
that's the torque of those two those two
pressures I think helped us you know but
that can be so paralyzing when you feel
like you have to treat everything with
such reverent reverence II that's a word
right sure why not Reverend a certain
reverence and Prevention reverence I
don't know guys this is my first day in
English is not my first language okay
I'm so sorry this 11 days only passing
this whole time I know
but how do you how do you you know force
yourself to break break out of that that
yeah
it's a great question and it's it was
really hard especially when it felt like
the eyes of the world or especially the
eyes of Twitter definitely are on you
you know and just you had for me it was
like coming from it from a point of view
of like a reverence like for key
definitely helped because he can kind of
throw a wrench in there anything to kind
of throw woody and the audience kind of
off to the side like like ducky bunny
for example having like attacking the
lady that little scene like just
anything that can surprise the audience
I think is like you're opening the world
and kind of showing like everything you
you know is there but we're showing you
more and I think that helps with that
yeah I thought the movie has a kind of
like fresh point of view that it's sort
of like percolating throughout the
duckie and bunny fantasy stuff in
particular I'd like this has a road of
time but got a couple hard balls okay
quickly who would win bow or an anaconda
under under water or on land this is
actually one of our talking points so I
know I know it's true I do have one real
question which is we know what answers
bow she has obviously it's about the we
have we know what it's like to be in
like a punch-up room we're like we're
all like you know they give us candy if
we like come up with silly joke what is
it like to be in like do you have like
heartbreak rooms where you just get your
most dramatic crew members all together
we try to make each other cry how does
it work we don't have heartbreak rooms
but I will say that the like for example
the scene at the very end where they're
saying goodbye to bust and everything we
brought all the animators in to look at
all of that sequence at one time we
wouldn't look at shot by shot we wanted
to see all together and we would work
through that entire scene you know in
half a day and by the end of the day we
were just emotional
just rekt just trying to act it out and
live through it and just remember
everybody's just kind of like dropping
and going okay I'll see you tomorrow oh
man well thank you guys so much it's a
beautiful wonderful so thank you fellas
and you guys can stay here because we're
actually gonna do a thing called the
cavalcade of chairs yes a bunch of
chairs are gonna come onto this stage
very quickly and we're gonna do a very
very talented people are gonna bring the
chairs let's give them all a very long
round of applause the cheer squad the
chair squad here they come
that was a good one that's good I'm
gonna give you a challenge I'm gonna
give you a quick challenge right there
see if you can handle it Oh Oh Chris
your Chi
I think listen we were running low on
time we want to talk to all the nice
talented filmmakers so come back up you
guys yes here yeah
I'd touched all these waters we'll just
be careful yeah I don't know Bonnie gave
me um Bonnie hosted this last year was
very gracious she gave me something that
yes big big ups to Bonnie she gave me
something really important which has
been passed on from one host to another
for now several years which is some
Purell thanks for that gonna use that
after I touch all these nice people
and one more round of applause for all
of these amazing filmmakers and their
five beautiful completely unique
completely different from one another
pictures we touched on this briefly with
Gingka but I wanted to ask everybody
else who if they had any thoughts about
how we can to increase representation in
our business I softball question I can't
tell you Jenko said that if you make
talent and competence the only measuring
device that you use in our case it turns
out that you know diversity tends to
happen just if that's the only measuring
tool you use and so I think what's
happening is I was gonna say naturally
every school that we stopped at we're
seeing mostly young women and like the
balances have really shifted from when I
and most of the people of my age group
attended animation programs at various
colleges it's mostly guys back then and
there's just been a shift shift in in
popular culture and the popularity of
animation and the accessibility of it so
not only do I see most mostly young
women studying animation but most of
them are from abroad you know so many
Asian students and so that's it's
inspiring because the work you know the
workforce is going to be flooded with
these students who are well trained and
capable and full of passion and big
ideas they're coming so I I imagine it's
just going to naturally shift the
balances I mean unless you're living
under a rock this it's what it is man I
mean that is that's our future that's
our soul it's humanity it's it's what we
are all about and so it's it's there's
there's there's actually there's not a
choice to it it's this is it man and
it's super cool because it means that we
get to all everybody gets to grow the
audience is better for it filmmakers can
be better for it our industry's
embracing it I think better
as best as any of the industries in the
film thing but it's it's so cool
it is so invigorating there's a bunch of
aspiring filmmakers in the audience that
doesn't have any advice for someone who
wants to do what you guys do draw that's
what I tell everybody that's the best
way to get your ideas down clearly and
quickly and that's communication and
just keep drawing don't use a computer
draw and I'm gonna say you know our
meetings about innovation remember that
it is art and technology combined
together so think about stories that you
can innovate I would add if I could
don't be afraid to fail actually embrace
failure look for it
because every time you failed if you
open to you know analyze why you'll
learn and you'll get better no matter
what you do so just failure is your
friend embrace it and I would say also
sorry don't be afraid to be different
and weird because most of times the
society don't like you know when they
are not able to to control people humans
so I think artists should be like the
little chaos into the system to make the
system alive and to make the system
works so we need artists need the
systems to exist but also the system
need little bit cows and sparks to exist
also
maybe one last thing I'd add to that is
partner partner with for any young
filmmakers whether you're in school or
just starting out
partner with those people who are really
dynamite in your peer group
there's too much time that gets spent
trying to network with people who've
already established themselves and have
you know films behind them and I think
that's always it's poor advice you know
to try to work work that angle and and
hope that you can advance your career
simply by having someone Godfather or
godmother you in it's about the it's
about the talent that surrounds you
those are those really dynamic
storytellers and editors and
cinematographers and animators that you
know you're going to replace you're
gonna be the generation that replaces
all of us and like I think Phil and
Chris are such a great example of they
found one another and they embolden one
another and so there's there's no
boundaries for those guys do you know
like I do have Roger Deakins email
fantastic question who has it
you're like a clairvoyant person Jeremy
and Chris when you guys were twins
separated at Birth was your wedding what
was it like reuniting and have you done
it 23andme when he won the Golden Globes
my mother thought it was me oh my god
don't tell her nobody tell Jeremy's mom
he's been keeping this lie going for
longer than the fair well one of the
things that's so neat about this and is
and I think what's so special about
putting these events on is you know is
letting folks see what the filmmakers
look like and demystifying that and know
that like their shirts are really
wrinkled and like there's
sar too short in the stuff and and so
and it part of that I think it does
anybody want to share a story of like a
moment when they got better as a film
maker and they made a mistake or a wrong
turn and how it made you grow and you
know an important lesson that you
learned along the way because we've all
sort of hopefully gotten better over
time or if one of you got worse you know
what happened the answer's no we don't
want to share Oh everybody that's fair
that's true it's been bit perfect since
birth I relate to that I can I can maybe
share a moment that yeah I thought it
was meaningful for me so it used to be
like this I I stopped being a 2d
animator and I decided to be a
storyteller and then develop project and
I would for six months working it and
then I would fly to LA and I have my
list of contacts I was gonna have all
these meetings and then I would have all
these doors slam in my face you know
because who was I you know and and then
I would kind of have a really sad trip
back home with my project on my lap you
know on the plane going what did I do
wrong you know and and and what it
really clicked for me was there's one
time where I left but I used to think
failure is I'm gonna go in and gonna
pitch my project and I never say no
that's failure right and then I realize
when I exit a meeting it's like wait
they didn't get it that is failure you
know because they can say no that's
their prerogative and that's fine but if
I fail to make him understand I am
failing it's not really shifting I mean
made me a better storyteller I think
that's a lovely answer
is there anything else that anybody
wants to share we or we have to get up
here because of the makeup is taking
that cut makeup and hairstyling that
comes after us but there's time for
anybody else as well as anything else
they want to share that we didn't cover
today well the only thing I want to
share is it through the you work you
will face so many boundaries but the
worst boundaries is the one that lies in
your head so go of it Harry
very nice I share one thing I just want
to say like this class of nominees and
animation is like the coolest class I
think I've ever seen in Academy and I'm
just so honored to be with you guys and
just that all of our films are so
different and it's just so great so
thank you for hosting this thank you
thank you guys listen pal I just want to
say one single things because all the
team not of the team and there is ten
people as a team of the film not so far
from here it was making this film I'm
here on the stage but it was really a
bad discussion with back runner cheese
storyboard and everything and so there
is only one share I keep it but maybe
you will have your share next just sit
[Applause]
it is true film is a very collaborative
medium and there's no more collaborative
version of film than animation which is
a real true team effort and so thanks to
any crew members that are here that I've
worked on any of the films that have
come out this year you guys
[Applause]
anyone else have any parting words to
share that we haven't covered so far
mm-hmm all right questions for Kristin
ville I have could you guys indulge me
in one very silly thing it's gonna seem
sad but it's totally not you guys
remember the old rankin/bass Hobbit
movie right that's a great movie so the
guy who was the voice of The Hobbit the
voice of Bilbo Baggins is my neighbor
Orson and he's 91 years old and he
passed away last night he's the greatest
guy he's so funny he's making everybody
laugh in heaven but since we're here as
part of the animation community will you
give Orson one last big round of
applause Nika here thank you guys and
thank you all for coming out this
morning it means a lot to see how how
many people came out to this it's really
really special and enjoy the rest of
your weekend thanks so much
Thank You Krista Phil
[Applause]
you